right the man accused of killing rapper
Nipsey Hussle is in custody after a two
day manhunt new video shows Los Angeles
County sheriff's deputies arresting 29
year-old Eric Holder yesterday now he is
expected to be charged with murder last
night Nipsey Hussle 'he's girlfriend
actress Lauren London posted on
Instagram for the first time since the
shooting she says quote I'm completely
lost I've lost my best friend my
sanctuary my protector Jamie yuccas is
outside the 77th division police station
in Los Angeles where Holder spent the
night Jamie good morning good morning
police received a tip around 1:15 p.m.
yesterday afternoon from somebody saying
they thought they had spotted Eric
Holder when officers arrived they
arrested him about 20 miles from where
the shooting occurred Los Angeles
officers quickly surrounded Eric Holder
and placed him in handcuffs almost 48
hours after police say he shot and
killed rapper Nipsey Hussle in broad
daylight mr. holder walked up on more on
multiple occasions and certainly came
back armed with a handgun the suspect
then fired several shots killing nipsey
and injuring two others
police say holder and nipsey previously
knew each other it appears to be a
personal matter
between the two of them and regards to
dispute and now I'll leave it at that
holders arrest brings some relief to a
community reeling from the loss of the
young hip-hop star who made a name for
himself in Los Angeles not only for his
music but for his efforts to curb
violence in the city even as a former
gang member
you killed a role model you killed a
leader you killed somebody that was
trying to save your life
Nipsey Hussle is a shining example of
the best of what we can be and the best
of what it means to seek and carry out a
redemptive charge
Nipsey had been scheduled to meet with
the police chief and the president of
the city's police commission just one
day after he was killed in an email
asking for the meeting he wrote he hoped
to help improve communication
relationships and work towards changing
the culture and dialogue between the
LAPD and inner city
Nipsey Hussle was an artist who touched
our city
and the lives far beyond the City of
Angels throughout this country and this
world holders being held here without
bail if he's convicted on that murder
charge he would face life in prison Gail
all right Jamie thank you the mayor is
calling today for the people to be calm
he says the absolute worst way to pay
nipsey back to pay back nipsey's losses
with more violence that's hope people
listen to him and it's interesting that
a community member turned him in which
is often not the case and these kind of
things but the community said we want
this guy to be caught Jamie we thank you
again